To address the places where our current visualization is lacking in terms of
communicating our message, one of the key things to focus on is how do
we efficiently and effectively communicate a change over time.
Our static chart shows the trend over time, but
what doesn't come across as clearly are some of the nuances in the data.
One way to address this might be to try visualizing our
data with finer granularity.
Instead of showing the aggregate attendance for a given year, let's see how it
comes across if we visualize every individual game and its attendance.
As I mentioned before, the next task at hand is removing the code in dimple.js,
that deals with axis, and coding it up in D3 itself.
Well, with this code here, both creates axis and
changes how the x axis is formatted.
We're simply going to remove all of it and build it back up in D3.
In lesson one we saw how to work with D3's extend and
scale functions to convert data values into proper pixel values.
The first step in figuring out how to draw our x and y axis in D3 is
to first find the extent of each of the columns which we'd like to visualize.
In this case our x axis is going to represent the date column, and
our y axis is going to represent the attendance.
Remember that the extent function finds the minimum and
maximum for a given data based on what you return from the assessor function.
In this case, as applied to our data, extent runs the function we've
passed on each element of our data, in this case the argument D.
And based on what you return from this function,
extent internally keeps track of the minimum and maximum values its seen.
The same principle applies to our attendance.
And notice that we're using the same function, d3.extent in both of these cases,
but since the function we're actually running is slightly different,
in the first case, we're returning date,
in the second case we're returning attendance.
time_extent and count_extent are actually very different objects.